you know when you get that first sitting
almost close your heart yes
welcome to work come on Eric well worth
it UK the show where we test three
different things that's three
drastically different price points to
determine which is the most worth it
I'm rich I matter tea connoisseur of the
fast this week the drink of the UK more
important than water pretty much
currency - you have about 20 cups a day
have - where's that genuine like 20
today without C means I haven't left my
bird some bleak day jaha who are you Rob
Joe honestly what about that seat there
first stop cabman shelter basically
fantastic spots to get tea the cab
drivers you don't have to be a kept oh
yeah they came in around 1800s a lot of
the time taxi drivers would take a break
but go into pubs these things were built
as a sort of rest stop didn't serve
alcohol so they were drunk driving
horses yeah
[Music]
my name is Tracy Edwards the cab man
shelters started back in 1875 so that's
why we have the bar to tie up the horses
anybody can order from the hatch but
only taxi drivers can come and sit
inside my process you just got to have
boiling water fresh tea bag and just
make individual tea for everybody I'm
very proud of my seven cepes cup of tea
can I have the Arsenal month please
actually becomes two key these are
specific mugs only these are the West
Ham one is my delivery man so some
builder at the window cool spider she's
everywhere and he bought this Crystal
Palace one so good on spider good on
spider
what would happen if Keith saw me do you
know his awesome face today you two are
just gonna have a founded cup of tea for
70 points from me
Tracy was incredibly kind and offered us
a seat in the shelter unfortunately our
sound man broke the rules it's peanut
ejected disgraced himself a little bit
you know what I call out this setting
well this is a nice Instagram wall all I
need is my horse tied up here Janet
beautiful cup of standard English
breakfast he doesn't get better than
that Tracy knows what she's doing she's
done like the perfect mix hasn't she the
first cup of a day this is everything I
need there's not really a science to it
it's more like second nature it's a
feeling for her if you think about the
amount of T that this shelters churned
out a thing may get my vote and the
price I mean do anything there's a pee
after it is a bargain these days right
yeah even a bottle of water's like at
least a pound inside joke
find that every time I have a tea is
with Abby
[Music]
you have a fact what's our phone our
teeth teeth teeth bad tea bags were
invented in 1908 No yeah Thomas Sullivan
from America that's true yeah okay Joe
where did you get these facts Wikipedia
we are off to timber-yard in Soho it
prides itself on the reverse osmosis it
uses with its water I don't know what
that means but it sounds very impressive
really interesting you said water tea is
the second most popular drink in the
world after water but I never drink
afterwards
[Music]
we're at timbi are in the half say hi my
name is Darren well especially after tea
and coffee so we wanted to make sure it
was really high quality we've sourced
some amazing teas the basis of our blend
is a Kenyan and then we have a Rwandan
it's more aromatic and it kind of lifts
the Kenyan a little so it balances it
off the final single origin tea and
there is a union from China which has a
natural smokiness with a little bit hot
cross bun like so a blend is like a tea
cocktail we use a reverse osmosis system
to filter our water creates the right
balance of minerals for a really
beautiful tea the service itself is a
bit of theatre we measure 5 grams of he
leaves that's brewed with water 93
degrees it's quite specific and then
left to sit with a digital timer and we
set it for 5 minutes it seems a long
time to a lot of people but this is
especially an TT it takes that a little
bit longer to brew really well it's a
different process a good 5 minutes for a
really lovely intense cup a part of our
English breakfast tea is 3 pounds 90 all
right so we have four and a half minutes
drive you got a joke for us
you know there are only two main types
of T uppercase and lowercase so bad that
it's running what do you want to do the
honors this is optimal time to pour the
tea oh look at the color it's like
almost as red as the cup Cheers
you know what I've discovered you're a
slapper no don't say that
what are you talking about I'm not
everyone be quiet did that that was
accidental
I thought the tea was closer to my mouth
and it was let me do it one more time
it's hot if you don't slurp it's really
hot bringing out sweat I get what he was
saying about the smell this would really
pair well with hot girl with the hot
cross yeah it is lovely - it's an
enhanced and Oh cuppa tea like you could
have this in your house but you'd
probably want it with a good show
something that's on once a week you want
the top up very good size there's some
places where the cops are almost too big
suppose I'm you finish your tea it's
cold
sometimes when I'm having a cup of tea I
like to balance it because I'm too lazy
to reach forward and put it on the
coffee table we're gonna have an
accident in a minute I really liked it I
just feel very content we want to say to
move off let's go but here you want tea
maybe a brownie maybe a bisque a little
chitchat Royal China Club in Marylebone
please mate okay no problem
next stop pretty fancy place prides
itself on its extensive Chinese tea
collection - fact
you know why they call it macho tape as
it's hard yes don't think they call it
mad
is it match ah I am Jason Chen PR
manager of the road china group UK we
don't add milk to the tea or sugar
included claim it's good for your health
cleansing there are different kinds of
tea is the air the humidity the weather
the soil the tea we're tasting today are
one of the most expensive diamond for a
50 years old the flavor is like the wine
a vintage tea we can only use special
tops only brew for typos otherwise
you'll ruin the clay but then surf in
two different jar
it means the tea leaf doesn't get you
know too much flavor out of it the first
fill pour out clean the area tea leaves
and the only second filling to start
drinking
there's so different country I can not
find some kind of words in English is
there anything in Chinese you would say
home Sutton is the feeling rather than
just to taste from the tongue there's an
experience yeah
sell it to the customer eighty pounds a
pot the most expensive tea we will
probably ever taste in our life are you
gonna shut it absolutely not it's all
shrouded in mystery I don't really know
what this tea leaves have seen exactly
where they've come from
I love how delicate it is I would buy an
incense candle of this I was just
thinking that thing is exactly like
incense you want this smell when you
having a massage you do this we're doing
this
Cheers
[Music]
that's a lot lighter than I expected I
think it's quite fee that tastes like
this kind of golden like I can't find
the right words to describe the taste of
it I don't know the words he just tastes
like tea yeah and then when you have
wood smokes fish and the smell you get
from that is basically the taste that
you get in this wood we've said that
another one just interesting is with the
other teas you take like a pretty big
gulp of it this you take a tiny section
I get the feeling this isn't even a
throat feeling I was talking about it's
an experience it's not it's not about
the taste buds it's about the feeling
you get right here Andrew you're the pro
tell us what flavors we're tasting in
this slurp ahh slurp in action nothing
wrong with it
it really dries out your mouth yeah
there's you working with it you really
like the Royal China Club I thought it
was smaller but Tim BR is my winner cuz
it's so cozy and he was eighty
connoisseur yeah your stuff in room but
my favorite is the cabin and shelter cuz
the Tracy oh yeah I love Tracy Tracy was
amazing I like just no-nonsense you know
yeah
Joe one word to sum each place our cab
man shelter a timber yard ro China Club
who told you you a tasty there'll be
something other than posh
[Music]
you